tell us what makes it so stingy so
here's the good news for Trump employees
his match is actually pretty good if you
contribute 6% he'll kick in four and a
half percent to your retirement the
issue is all the hoops you have to jump
through to get there gotta wait a year
until you can participate you got to
wait until the end of a calendar year
before that matching contribution shows
up and Trump's money doesn't become your
money until six years after you've
started working there so not fully
vested until six years I mean that is a
huge amount of time is that are there
other companies that that are like this
or does he really stand out among
companies so 401 k's are all over the
map you have some that do have some of
these features some other plans that do
have all these features you have others
including the plan of NBC which aired
his show The Apprentice that are much
more generous that allow investing in
the first year so these plans are really
all over the place and it's it often can
be hard to compare this one is for
someone who talked about his success and
being the best at everything this one is
middle of the road to lower the middle
of the road right it seems average or
below average here okay so what what
about the Trump Organization what have
they said about this Richard they
haven't said anything with this this
information all comes from federal
filing so they have to disclose every
year how their plan is doing what the
features are of it and for a few years
they're one of the things they disclose
is that they'd stop matching
contributions altogether so from March
of 2009 through June of 2012 there was
no matching contribution that's usually
something companies do when they're in
some sort of financial trouble you know
there are private company so we don't
know what their full books look like but
they like a lot of companies in the
recession suspended that match and it
took them a little longer than a lot of
others to resume it